I'll bail you I'll basically overreacted
your call wouldn't go through I promise
you none of your calls would go through
all you man Ram toes Jade none of your
calls will go through
I already have a new number I've started
a new life
[Music]
guys and girls as we normally do we go
straight into the question of the week
we don't waste time we just get to the
juicy flipping juice yeah and here we
are and the question of this week was
how did you find out your friend wasn't
really your friend good a couple good
responses
I'm gonna say there was at least 400
girls saying that their friends of
course I just add all of that yeah yeah
yeah yeah typical the standard yeah yeah
yeah so I just add all of those all
right cool
um apart from one yeah let's go and I'll
start with that all right she took my
man twice
twice bro that's your fault factual the
first time for me once yeah yeah that's
your fault she took your man then for
some reason you took your man back and
then she snagged him again again that's
your you yeah yeah you have no
protection of embarrassment that is your
fault you deserve it sorry you literally
um they organize plans without me in a
separate group chat oh that's good
in a separate group chat and just
leaving me there in the main well and
you you have no idea anything's going on
I really have no idea I just think the
chat is quiet yeah yeah because it's
quiet sometimes it's quiet sometimes
it's active it's one of them days to me
I just think it's quiet it's quiet
we're Topgolf
Bulls pause and I'm gonna be living yeah
I could never snap that day yeah you man
couldn't snap anything
the shock on my face if you found out
if you screenshot it and put it in
either whole group chat the shock on my
face you know do you know what it
actually reminds me of do you remember
REM when we went to it was all of us
went to the
um was it Marvin's birthday thing and
they told us Anthony came out and told
us that was Anthony that came out and
told us they said all these men went
table tennis and invite us fam I was
live livid
it was so casual about it as well oh so
kind of like James was so angry I'm
literally asking like yo bro so where
were you man and they're like oh just
just obviously obviously so how's
playing table tennis playing table
tennis like we declined in impactual
like they only had so many girls
I was fuming listen to explain on that
one yeah it was not airing anyone yeah
me the four of us were staying in the
same Hotel me Nick Jade and uh Jay all
in the same Hotel shortage houses is
around the corner as you well know
yeah so as we were on our way to meet
you yeah Jay suggested oh let's dip in
there have a few rounds get your pinkies
up yeah and then we'll just
to pass the time because it wasn't me in
time yet we'd agreed to meet at a
certain time so on the way there we just
dipped in there just quickly quick half
an hour grabbed a drink pinged some
balls and came back Anthony made the
whole thing worse than it needed to be
Master dead man all went and played
table tennis that's crazy well it's fast
he took me back because he wasn't even
there yeah he wasn't even there nothing
to do with it wasn't there yeah he's
Opps who does that Fabi literally came
out to dance spotted us across the road
I was like do you mind not go play table
tennis with Jay and James I'll say less
but safe how are you man doing that this
is before we got there before you now
got there well we were actually ready
yeah I'm already and then Toby's back to
us we will never think our toes it goes
well say less
sorry don't be
how did you find out your friend wasn't
your friend
she asked me not to get in her wedding
picks as I'll make her look bad I was
the maid of honor
making that sense that's a jealous make
it make sense bro what do you mean she
wasn't made of honey you can't be in the
pics you're gonna make me look bad if
you're getting the picks yeah like it
was like you're too banging
people are just gonna be like who is
that facts you're gonna steal away the
Limelight from the main thing I by the
way yeah obviously first of all just
don't make a maid of honor in fact just
don't have one facts I would hate to
have a bridge and that's overly overly
overly overly laying I would I would I
would I would hate it like you're tight
Regin like Thai boy and to the point
where everyone's like oh who is that who
is that yeah yeah who actually is that
it would become frustrating for years of
this yeah mentally frustrated I think
it's one of those ones where if they're
actually my boy like but like let's say
you you like you like I wouldn't even
I'll just have to charge it bro yeah
we'll just have to charge it because
because he also isn't allowed to be
successful you're banking that he's not
successful
he's just a pretty bredresser yeah yeah
yeah yeah because if he's successful as
well yeah because if successful as well
then he's keeping them because he's
attracting them in the first place and
then he's and he's keeping them those
jokes keeping them as jokes
um all right let me run it back um we
kept stealing girls from each other oh
Jesus he's a bad friend they're both
they're bad friends we kept stealing
girls from each other
pause one sec actually
I remember there was one time he didn't
steal her from me not even close but
this guy over here this is years ago yes
you already know what he wants to say no
no no no no
oh yeah this is uh second year of uni or
whatever like that we're chilling um and
I bought my girlfriend at the time
that's the first day I've met her
to the flight you might have been at our
flat as well at the time second year
Beauty second year of uni you might have
been there you might not have been there
okay revitos was definitely in there
um callous callous yeah yeah so she came
around to the spot
I took her in the kitchen because I knew
that man went there Jabron was in there
these men were in there you may or may
not have been in there watering and was
like oh it was this is you I think I
feel like you were because I think I was
yeah and I was like this is such and
such x uh this is Aaron this is a this
is a and she was like cool cool didn't
say nothing
um
walk back and then uh huh whereas in my
room chilling and then she was just
asking about the friendship and audience
yeah and I was like yeah yeah it's all
good like we stay up here um we like go
gym together and all the stuff and then
um I was like oh yeah like Aaron bangs
gym and she was like I know I saw the
arms
a lot
but did you see mine yeah because you're
you're looking like you saw everyone's
arms for yum facts
her tongue clicked
she said I know I saw the arms I was
like what do you mean he was in there
for three seconds okay why you got time
to be seeing arms they're just at
they're in it it's that that's like me
that's like her like me and her bedrooms
and she was like oh yeah like Sarah
loves the gym and I'm like I know I saw
the ass I saw the back I saw the cheeks
I saw the glutes I saw the glutes from
the front you don't have to tell me
again you don't need to tell me anything
oh yeah I saw a shelf
yeah don't don't spit rhetoricals at me
I saw what I saw oh God yeah oh I was
living you never told him no why would I
tell him that news to me that's fair
yeah and then that era he had enough
pump true he had enough wife beater
error wife beater error yeah that double
that black and white one yeah I used to
lay her up when I was walking down the
road I used to lay her up I remember
this one time we went to a festival in
Cove do you remember
um yes sure there that one Lady Godiva
uh Fest yeah I swear yeah I don't
remember that but he was like two weeks
out from a show okay shredded shredded
he was what he went to get a juice and
walked back and he was walking across
the field and I remember I was looking
at him and he went like that just to
throw off he winged something like that
I saw him scream
I sort of Scream
I've never been so upset in my life
Flash's tummy I saw her off the screen
and he winked at you and he winked at me
yeah yeah oh Jesus
yeah Remy you cleaned up yeah back then
he cleaned up five days now look at you
[Laughter]
oh
my gosh
oh boy I was livid bro I was like this
kid's just on stuff on stuff he's not
even trying
now
it's annoying it's so annoying oh he was
dedicated he was dedicated had things to
do yeah you were just training
trying to winking at my frustrating oh
darling bro and you just kept getting
bigger and bigger pause and pause he's
just getting massive
I was sucking his stomach trying to do
chassis all the time
I was livid bro Madness people asking
why don't you start going with Aaron I
was like I do I've been I've got years
I've been going Jesus Christ man
anyway sorry but I'm not say it look at
you it's all love
um how did you find out your friend
wasn't really your friend there was a
Skype chat slagging me off months of it
you know
[Laughter]
spice wow chat wow they wanted out of
the way not the usual socials
nah bro that's terrifying news that's
terrifying news wow
cool yeah this is a juicy question took
a photo of me and sent it to me saying
this is why I can't talk to you I was in
chemo
that's dread that's this is why I can't
talk to you took a picture of me and
sent it to just pale just bail bold and
pale why I can't talk to you and that's
disrespect well I'm hooked up facts bro
oh wow she had a baby with my husband
foreign
she had a baby with my husband women
need the mail they see fives they want
nothing yeah it can't be equivalent
it's mad it can't be equivalent it can't
somewhat look like the man of my dreams
it has to be him and
they get there's one thing women do like
men get fooled women manipulate men men
get fooled on a daily so you lot don't
think for a second I'm I'm saying men
are any better they're far worse yeah
yeah yeah but when a woman is when a
man's willing to cheat on his wife
the higher the stakes the penis she
thinks she must be yeah makes sense so
if I'm willing to cheat on my wife with
you who's your best friend
[Music]
like down the road the higher the wrist
the higher the risk they think
you must want it he loves me he loves me
when really is thinking this is for
better yeah yeah that's all it is yeah
yeah these cheeks are exciting me yeah
what do you mean you're my wife's best
friend and you're on it
I'm gonna run through that yeah
to be saying she's saying I'm keeping it
because obviously you love me more than
her oh my God have you lost your mind
I'd want to scream I'd want to rip my
skin off so no one can have me
regardless I'm getting caught no one can
happen I'll get my skin off James
flipping out
that's nuts oh it's not that's too much
man that's too much that's a that's a
consequence you can not face because you
were leaving it in because it felt too
yeah good it was too ripe yeah I could
never think that it was too right yeah
that was the perfect concoction yeah
attempt to feel yeah the temp to feel
everything plus the Forbidden nature it
just made it sweet sweet yeah yeah so
when she said leave it in you had no you
weren't thinking straight he had no
choice and then she said boy it's ours
when are you leaving her I'm pregnant
when are you leaving her
that how are we gonna sit her down and
get her through this sit her down yeah
she's an OP from the jump I'll go white
as a ghost
I'd have to leave because there's no
reasoning with her yeah yeah fast
there's no reasoning always facts yeah
cause she she's in total control
the total control I'll have to leave the
state I'm deep to the afternoon mistake
I'd have to start new life you man don't
understand how fast I start again
I'll be sending you man links to studios
in Canada
saying what's going on like hurry up
pack up we have to move back up yeah
because she knows this location yeah she
knows where we're at yeah we need to
find a new tank fax bro block her now
Rock both of them facts yeah because no
one can over the new stew is yeah facts
facts that's long bro right how did your
friend find out how did you find out
your friend wasn't really your friend
um I match their voice in an argument
once they started telling what everyone
I'm emotionally unstable
can you imagine just because I raised my
voice too I'm emotionally unstable
yeah that's mad she sent me pics of
bridesmaids dresses of bridesmaid's
dress options and then didn't have me as
a bridesmaid
just want my feedback that's a piss take
you just want my feedback that's like us
man saying oh one of you all of you
might say to me are what do you think
about this hotel for this holiday blah
blah blah
Every Man's booked it and like oh yo
when's When's this holiday what hotel do
we put were we picking um big man you
might reply oh it's been booked we're at
the airport you've I wasn't invited
Jay I don't you man don't understand how
much I would freeze I would look at my
phone shaking
because it's not in my calendar I talk
to you every day bro and you're at the
airport now
you come out of the studio smash yeah
smash James
me and Megan have a hard time sorry but
I said he's done ah yeah I'll be getting
an individual contact contract
should be yeah
I'm going to see that when I'm on a
beach I've got to see a PDF come through
I'll bail you I'll basically
overreacting
your call wouldn't go through I promise
you none of your calls would go through
all you man REM toast Jay not even calls
will go through
I already have a new number I've started
a new life
because this is unfair
oh I'm starting your life bro I'll be so
angry ah chill man chill I'll be so
angry oh you man honestly couldn't do
that for me oh God you couldn't do that
to me bro I'll be so I'll whine to my
mom oh I need to speak to anyone I
wouldn't I wouldn't be able to face my
mom's text the next day asking her how's
my favorite CEO and all her star mates
because I have no friends anymore
wow and then your thing is your mum will
look at you like common denominator if
all of them felt comfortable with this
what did you do what did you do I think
I've got no you need to tell me all four
of them signed off facts bro and I'm
just here and you're in England yeah
yeah you man I do not buy people I did
something look at yourself what did you
do wrong I'll be so angry what did you
do wrong they're all God fear of men and
they did this to you look at yourself I
am the common denominator stop pointing
fingers at people let them enjoy their
holiday trust me the PDF will
come so quick oh I know oh I know so
cool I'll be so scared because I'm like
this guy's lost his mind I'll be belly
Megan I'll be belly Megan sort him out
I'll be so angry all right
I slept with his girlfriend he really
showed his true colors when he found out
no he's the original up oh he's shared
his true colors Oh my days Fab oh that's
a joke I'm sweating it today bro jokes
oh that's funny oh my days
yeah she stole from me and they
proceeded to tell everyone that I was
broke wow that's not that's even funny
that's a huge mistake
when he was licking his forks and
putting it back with the clean ones we
can't be friends
I promise you wow caught him trying to
sell my airpods on eBay for the fourth
time
help me and I'll help you
wow my friend of four years banged my ex
when I confronted her she said we're not
friends oh
wow we're not friends that's why I
banged him
she jokingly called my boyfriend her
husband they've been dating for three
years now
that's treacherous mom these men just
stopped caring
treacherous when I found a text in my
bm's phone saying I know you missed this
day
I know you missed this day and she would
probably what
because I was nervous three eyes just it
probably was that's the worst thing I
could see
I know you Mrs D followed by Prius and
that's it end of Converse they've
obviously linked that yeah literally
literally literally literally are scream
it's tough man I wouldn't be able to
handle stuff like that yeah
we have these conversations and I'm
thinking
these are just think it's a catchphrase
at this box but I can't experience stuff
like that and I don't know how there's
human beings out there have been through
stuff like that I know I know the worst
thing I've had is like I said before
when I saw the message on my from my um
my ex and said How's boyfriend number
two oh from my ex's bedroom to my accent
house boyfriend number two oh my God
that's
that's heinous yeah and there was no sex
chatting there whatsoever that all just
that I was like
what
boyfriend and I also didn't know who
boyfriend number two was is it me
is it me
wow is it me because she went she went
different years yeah yeah was I sight
they wrote this my head was doing
backflips I was thinking who's boyfriend
number two bruh are you mad and then I
thought what if I'm boyfriend number two
because you don't you didn't see her
after I saw on holidays
it was long distance I saw her once a
week on a Wednesday and summer holidays
you might have she was living on campus
might have been in bf2 I may have been
inside I never deeped it like that
before same damn
yeah yeah it was treacherous damn
anyway lost two
um how did you find out your friend
wasn't really your friend
she told me there was a guy she wanted
to set me up with come to find out it
was the guy she was currently cheating
on a husband with and that was the
excuse for them to hang out in public
together
[Music]
so a side man was like I'm tired of this
hotel stuff I'm tired of this back Cali
Stacks play me or don't fax and she's
like all right say let's I'm gonna shout
out yeah pretend you man out on a date
and then we'll go out as a trio yeah and
he's like fine that's what he needs to
be that's why it takes bro that's
different all right last one reunited at
University after so many years I got
robbed after freshers welcome party the
same night and I knew it was him because
the assailants called me by my native
name which I hadn't used in years Oh
wrong the assailants
my native name
that's nuts Oh my days yeah that that's
how you know this was an inside job bro
can you imagine being
oh bro can you imagine yeah imagine this
it's the middle of the night yeah yeah
it's the middle of the night yeah and
you wake up to a leather glove around
your neck oh God oh God
me and two are not me but
I've ruined the whole game
two of my prayers are there Nick round
your neck I've brought it protest it's
me
what this is me bro
yeah love a glove around your neck
[Laughter]
charade bro right never gonna run your
neck bro you wake up your shot yeah yeah
you're shocked bro there's three
brothers in your bedroom yeah
out I wasn't expecting that yeah
yeah
turtleneck yeah and just nothing else
boots and nothing
socks and boots high socks and boots
steel toe caps and just clock out yeah
every man's heart
next thing spun over clap clap clap clap
you know what's going down clap clap
clap clap clap and I said don't even
bother trying to fight it yeah yeah and
the last the last light skin that runs
in you must say oh flakes man
and we we Scurry up into the night I
don't even know I said it
Quakes man oh flakes man
pulled out not pulled out dead were your
tips
[Laughter]
because it's mad because
I would hear your voice and thinking
that sounds too much like James and it's
crazy because I wouldn't necessarily
first of all think it's one of our my
boys obviously everyone here calls me
swags but people call me face because
you might call me yeah so I think it's
someone that watches the show that's my
thirsty because I would never believe it
I couldn't believe it's you yeah yeah
because I couldn't Buck you here on a
Thursday and make eye contact
but as soon as you make contact that you
remember you you remember that the grip
as soon as we look eyes you see the
Hazelnut and you're like nah it was you
I wouldn't know how to confront it yeah
because I wouldn't know
I wouldn't know whether
I would be able to address it because I
wouldn't know whether you would want to
expose that about yourself because I
don't know who the other two assailants
are I just know one of them is You by
locking eyes yeah because if I now
address it and let's say it's not remin
J or remin Ellis yeah so like
am I exposing you no yeah do you know
what I mean yeah I was so confused yeah
I'd be so confused at how nonchalant you
are about it yeah
like this is your day-to-day this is
your week yeah I hate you from the depth
of my soul bro of course
from the depths of my soul my G I
wouldn't be able to believe you do oh
you've been planning this for 15 years
yeah yeah you've known me
you know me and you know I just wanted I
just wanted to know I just wanted to
really know you were my target
use this whole thing this has to do is a
koi
oh I just want free access my goodness
oh God no James oh and you just oh it's
mad and then like you you get confirmed
you lock eyes yeah and you get confirmed
and then you start talk and then I just
randomly slip out on a pod that I've got
like vitilago on my left cheek oh my God
yeah that's a raven and it just floods
into your head and you imagine me right
right now and you just see that
discoloration on the left cheek and
you're like
him all along
wow yeah
it's good
you know I'm sweating even more because
I will start thinking of reasons as to
why
like you've said certain stories in
certain ways before like for example
you've always said to me or you've
always said on the show like every time
you're banging and you not once you've
not you put your boxes straight back on
I'll be like is that why he does it do
you know what I mean I'll start thinking
of yeah bro that's a bit of
lager oh my God
I forgive you of course
how would I see because this is the
longest game we've ever played and I
will never forgive you I'm sick
I'm sick and I I will be in such an
internal conflict because
can I let this money go yeah fine let
this lifestyle go should I shut the
up yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah conflict yeah okay you confront me
and all I do is bring up the business
accounting what do you really want to do
I'm bringing the business account and I
you a job application to the ivy so
which one do you want to do a job
vacation happened with a picture yeah
pin down because you might sucker yeah
woke up losing like a baby
would you really what do you want to do
and before you ask I rip up as my four
Gang character
I would
I would play the longer himself I would
find a way to kill you
I would find a way to ruin your life my
bro I don't think you get it oh this
reminds me of I told you I'm in my um uh
Korean bag at the moment yeah watching a
series called The Glory yeah
um long story short it's based on a um
they flip back and forth between pastors
and present tense and the moral I say
the more of the stories behind um a
chick that got broadly did when I say
you've never seen bullying like it oh
Jesus she got bullied in high school so
I've set the scene right she got draped
into the gymnasium uh where they play
basketball whatever and there's like
five or six guys in their people girls
and guys they're dragging this chick
right the main character they're
dragging or drapes and they're saying
I'm gonna test how hot my curling iron
is on you every single day what she what
you just said is what exactly what she
said she said what and she was sometimes
she said what they drape stuff now Drake
and it's just screaming no I bet she was
like they left honored they left it on
no no no no no no no no no no no no no
it's hot enough they're cold probably
she was screaming crying mama was just
there throwing up freeze it was guys
throwing up freeze bro he's letting it
happen he's letting it happen that's one
torture that was one torture scene that
was one torture symbol you know you've
never seen torch I like it yeah bully
this stole she nearly jumped yeah yeah
bro she nearly got she went to the top
of the roof and nearly jumped instead of
juice every day they did his fam
all over
all over James
so when I say she's playing the long
game yeah fast forward about five six
years later yeah she said well I think
faster yeah she said I'm coming for all
of you oh I'm coming for all of you
she said my dream is to see you every
day I'm Gonna See You in My Dreams every
day
fast four five five years later or
whatever
where I'm at is um the woman I got burnt
is now a teacher she now teaches she's
now the Homing teacher of the main
villain's daughter oh she's playing oh
dear no no the glory is
it catches me bro okay cool it sounds um
yeah it sounds terrifying I said why
you've not seen torture like it you've
not seen bullying I promise you the
second I get burnt I'm jumping
I promise you now after how bad the
first day was I think you're trying to
shoot you're not doing that every day if
they did the next day I'm jumping bam
there was a they did a flashback to
another bullying time it's same
gymnasium they were choking her for
eight seconds
one shot was recorded there were token
for eight seconds and they let her go
and then yeah that was recording and
tiger she said you're meant to pass out
after eight seconds it didn't happen
choker again
anymore what do you mean
family the scenes in there
I'm sweating yeah I can see bro sweating
toasty in it the scenes in that oh there
was let me give you one more Scene bro
yeah so after the burning thing right
yeah she went to like the school nurse
or whatever when I say the burner all
over James they burn that all over
stop there's a scene when she went to
the school dots or whatever yeah and she
just wanted to get um she knew she
coincidentally knew what she needed to
do that yeah coincidentally because of
another flashback so she's like oh let
me get X some peroxide whatever I can't
remember what it's called and the nurse
was like why the do you need that
blah blah blah show me she pulled up her
sleeve she's like who did this to you
who did this to you if you're scared we
can go to the principal together
again uh nurses roommate there's a
couple beds there was a bed that had the
curtain wraps around it phone rang in
that curtain room it rang it was the
it rang she didn't even talk she
opened the thing so they could see it
was her she said let me call you back
she said the first one that jumped is me
and I was the man the one that nearly
made a jump too what are you gonna do
about it
the next day she tries to go to the
thing the nurse's office said uh this
office has been closed due to the
resignation of the nurse
when I say these these people are child
go out the nurse bro but when I say
these people have money and power that's
why they bully nah they said there's
nothing you can do to me because I have
money my parents are money and have
power this is like giving like Gossip
Girl bro it's Gossip Girl or steroids
yeah yeah wow what do you like it I'm
moving country I was wrapped in I bet
wow
I promise you you're not burning me more
than two days in a row it's over I'm not
even exactly they burn that all
over from after the second day is done
the bully is done I was screaming
assembly bro I'll let everyone know
there's no there's nothing else you
could do to me I'm not getting burned
more than twice in a row
that's my limit facts bro more than two
seconds on this on the skin they put
their parts
is there no one to kick or nothing there
was like seven man they held her down my
bro bro arms and legs and neck they
Bender Ah that's not on man the next one
was just shooting her ass
lot
yeah bro the difference between rich and
poor there's literally difference
between rich and poor she was poorly
buried
they put in another one that she jumped
bro and she said I'm the reason she
jumped fat what are you saying what are
you gonna do if she opened that
I'm saying what do you think I'm gonna
do so let me talk to you later let me
handle this
I'm attacking her
she has the scariest Joker face oh okay
when I say she she's when she's burning
you or when and the maddest thing she's
the one that doesn't really actually
inflict the pain she commands people oh
she oversees it and she's the Kingpin
the way she Revels in it it's it's
fantastic acting yeah but it's like wow
like you're in character okay so let's
say less the smile is crazy right like
um
what's that gambling anime kakaguri on
um I don't watch it I've not watching it
I know exactly what happened
sadistic I swear I swear banging animal
okay okay
that's where they go into a school with
there's no rules in this school okay
it's a high school that runs on gambling
everyone's always betting and gambling
something when I say
if you ain't got money if you've lost a
few bets yeah but roll if if someone
challenges you to a gambling or you're
trying to do a gameting and you ain't
got the money to pay up yeah they'll Lop
off your ear they'll lob take out your
eye they're getting their money
they're going to get what you're owed
bro yeah and then once you've got
nothing left and it's proven that you've
got nothing left because you're just
murdered yeah yeah man then we'll run up
and now just try and rape you because
you ain't got clout in the school you've
got nothing that's crazy it's nuts
you're chopping me up and if I don't
have the money still you're gonna rape
me bro I'm laughing it's not funny they
move mad in there but the main character
she's like an exchange student or
whatever yeah she's run up and seen and
say what's going on I lie what's going
on where's the principle and then they
let their love new me of course they
know that you don't know how yeah yeah
so let's say oh do you want to play like
dominoes or snap or something and they
put a bit of fun and all right let's
play a little we'll put 10 pound down
and she's like yeah sounds fun and then
it gets heated but they learn quickly
she's on it oh yeah yeah so she's like
oh I don't have any more money she's
like let's let's find let's let's bet
our pinkies let's bet our pinkies if
you've got no more money and she'll say
bet
[Applause]
I ain't seen it but I'm sure it's on
Netflix so he's on Netflix right yeah so
I've I've seen it but we've not seen it
I've reached past a few times and
thought okay what's that say yes
I've never seen the trailer I've just
seen it on Netflix okay she loves it
okay yeah she learns a few episodes of
she's like I'm sick
because every time because they
sexualize it as well so I don't go
because wet when all's on the stake
I loved it
I loved it that's a destiny yeah wow no
it's not say less it's a good anime
right welcome back guys yeah episode 303
of your favorite party standard um
fighter Flakes and Jimmy D we're here
today to um hopefully have a laugh this
is this is the funniest start I've had
in a minute bro my head's pounding I'm
sweating but yeah man welcome back guys
obviously we are very very we're
steamrolling through to that million
we're Steam from it so please guys
subscribe if you're watching Youtube
please subscribe to the channel and
please please guys oh I forgot to say it
right guys
the reaction Channel when oh thank you
so thank you guys you men are
nuts yeah it went off it went off bro so
we're now recording this a few days
behind where you're at right now
um but yeah what was so if you had
wanted to get 25k in one week and I said
shut up yeah you said 10K in a day I
said 10K in a day and then fear said I'm
bougie let's go 25k and I was like I'm
just gonna say the word weak and hope he
agrees with me yeah because 25k in a day
is impossible so it's been three days
ish
um since we released it's been three
days and we are currently on 66.9 K
that's that's mad
I'm telling you 100K in a week
100K in a week it's gonna happen
yeah you guys are the literally the best
fan base anyone could ever ask for it's
physically impossible how banging you
guys are so thank you so so so so so
much that's that's different gravy
that's literally different gravy
um so guys obviously if you haven't
already head on over to shits and gigs
react sucks uh subscribe to that channel
for us guys obviously if you're really
about you already know what you need to
do you need to head on over to
patreon.com sheets and gigs and donate
contribute pay homage uh three pound a
month don't be a day you need to run the
P two sng your cult daddies are here to
supply The Good Vibes the real real good
vibes
um Supply that to us and indoctrinate
yourself into the cult for real for real
become a cult baby so your daddies can
show you a better life
show you how to really really live how
to chirps how to laugh and then you can
binge three and a half years worth of
episodes on there so much man bro we've
got hundreds of episodes over on patreon
so
fill up on that pause and also join our
Discord guys where everyone's having a
chin work everyone's having a good time
yeah mom
um and yes Vibes over on patreon so
please jump over there cheers and guys
obviously you can't forget about the
audio listeners audio listeners if uh if
you really do really Vibe with us please
whatever app you're on leave us a nice
review
uh give us five stars it's preferable
but whatever you do say it was your
chest okay guys take a very very very
very very quick break you know the
routine listen close this summer it's
not about the size of those cannonballs
it's about making a splash with our
friends over at manscaped prep for
barbecue season by making sure your
Grill Master has the hottest dogs The
Summer's ever seen let's go when you're
at the cookout let the meat speak for
itself come on let's go let the me speak
for itself with manscape's performance
package 4.0 it's time to get ready and
not sweaty by going to madscape.com and
using this simple code sng Sierra
November Golf and that's going to get
you a cheeky 20 off plus free shipping
thank you very much let's get back to
the episode and let's get into it guys
it is time for the Legendary game that
we play on this show which is five let's
go everyone get your white balls out get
your markers and if you're at home
listening watching make sure you're
playing along as well right I don't know
if you guys remember but I did say last
week that this week's one is going to be
a little bit different
and this top five isn't a top five but
it's still categorized as the top five
so the question is
how tall do you think X is oh okay so
I'll give you people you write you give
me the heights that's it and obviously
if it boils down to a tie breaker I've
got extra Heights that your bank can
give me right these are going to be
celebrities yeah so I will name the
person yeah it's celebrity yes just to
clarify right I will name the person you
guys just write the height yeah cool
I'll go from there because if it was
like it's not just like I'm not gonna
say Ellis if it was each of us in here
then there's like trigger warning if
someone gets something wrong
there's a couple man might add a couple
inches you know I know I am say less all
right you guys ready yeah all right
guess the hype Tom Holland Stephen
Gerard Raphael Nadal Nicki Minaj last
but not least guess the height
you go first uh so Tom Holland give me
your hype
Tom Holland I'm saying five nine uh
Stephen G six two uh Nadal five eight
Nicki Minaj five four and Gal Gadot 510
Ellis
Tom Holland five eleven Stevie G five
nine Rafael Nadal six two Nikki five
free Gal Gadot
five six Jimmy Tom Holland five eight
DVD six one Rafa and uh five eleven
Nikki five seven gal five ten cool
right Tom Holland
the answer is five foot eight gang
so Jimmy's got one so far let's go
Stevie G the answer is so just just to
clarify ls59 rem62 Jimmy six one the
answer is six foot
no no no
Rafael Nadal
Jimmy 511 Rams five eight L is six two
the answer is six one ah wow surprising
rougher six one
Nicki Minaj Jimmy put five seven REM
five four and his five three she's
actually five two
damn okay do you know where I put that I
saw something against
Lil Wayne one time she was over a little
Wednesday five four though yeah yeah so
I was like damn she what definitely was
wearing heels she must have been yeah it
added deep it yeah fair play and uh
galgado
um
Jimmy 510 Ram 510 ls58 and the answer is
510.
gang oh Jimmy you want that one then
yeah by far yeah like four right no he's
not too right he got two right he only
got the first he got Tom Holland and
Gaga oh he uses way closer to me on all
of them then yeah Remy you got that guy
right I got the last one right here
Ellis got none right I had a couple
tiebreakers Jessica shut up and that's
it as usual yeah I hope you guys learned
a little side about people's lights damn
fair play man that's easy back in the
lead for Jimmy then what's it now 7662
yeah
don't do stuff like that oh nice man
fair play
so apparently the internet says I'm five
foot oh yeah I remember you I remember
yeah it says you're fine you showed me I
showed you that yeah someone said it
yeah people said it to me all the time
it was five foot and 65 kg
killed me
they think I'm a little baby ah you lift
you up they're banging you yeah
Darren it's hilarious bro hilarious cool
man but yeah that's nice decent uh nice
change to the to the top five
um and you've got a dilemma for us yeah
I do have a dilemma for you guys guys I
need some advice
my partner has been working away since
August I saw him for three days over the
new year and haven't seen him since but
we communicate regularly via WhatsApp
both text and video calls
a few weeks ago his phone synchronized
with my pc at home and downloaded all of
his his internet history unbeknownst to
me
I opened the browser on my PC and it
loaded the last web page that was opened
on the outside device it opened up onto
a cam girl site in Brackets no judgment
to the girls props to them people have
their their own way of making pee
somewhere and it can be a very viable
source of income Sharp
like we didn't need that caveat
this didn't bother me initially but chat
windows at the bottom did he'd been
talking to them he he's been talking the
most to these girls in ways he used to
talk to me but that has dropped off
while he was working away
we've had conversations in the past
about porn and campsites porn doesn't
bother me in the slightest everyone
watches porn anyway
how how I was close to starting an of a
while back but backed up because of my
severe body confidence issues ETC
and said that I wasn't going to do that
whilst I was in a relationship unless it
was solely coupled content as I feel it
would be a disrespectful to him while he
said that he has well sorry while he
said that he's had an account on a cam
girl site in the past he didn't know the
login details anymore I would never go
to those sites ever again now that we
are together
I told him that I wouldn't feel
comfortable with him going to see these
sites but that I wouldn't stop him but
that communicating with them either
publicly or privately was no was a hard
no for me and I would feel disrespected
if he did what the hell do I do this
is going on cancer it's
talking to random girls online from all
over the world when I'm right here and
he could be doing exactly the same thing
for one and could be doing exactly the
same thing for him showing him and what
he's missing at home what do I do so
long story short she just hates the fact
that he talks to gam girls while she's
away they've not seen each other since
the turn of the new year and they only
speak via WhatsApp video calls this that
any other and
she has no qualms about girls doing of
or girls doing campsites or whatever she
just hates the fact that he's talking to
them in a way that she used to talk to
her and now no no anymore he doesn't
speak cratter anymore
um what should I do
sauce
it's not really I was gonna say it's
tough It's a really tough one but
um charge it
um because there's no coming back
because like the thing is is like I
don't know what else yeah it's just to
charge it she has to charge it
she has to charge it because like I'm
thinking if I'm the guy yeah and I'm
doing all this stuff knowing it's not
allowed yeah
it's not allowed it's not allowed yeah
she's made it adamantly clear it's not
allowed and I'm doing it anyway I
haven't seen you in time yeah
there's nothing you can say because if
you like
if you if you if you tell me that you've
clocked me I'll just stop for your sake
yeah not because I want to stop yeah
like it's not like oh my God I needed
someone to clock me so I could stop yeah
yeah yeah and stop because I'm
embarrassed yeah and now I'm just in
internet cafes
oh that yeah that's when you know you're
diving inside yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah I need that different IP address
yeah facts wow now I'm just using up
vpns and I'm on Incognito always also I
just clocked this um downloading
whatever unbeknownst hers cast to be
gash uh what is she say oh the the
devices a few weeks ago his phone
synchronized with my pc at home and
downloaded all of his internet history
unbeknownst to me in what world does
that happen
how does that happen I don't think
that's true it's
obviously you can sync up the um if it's
an iPhone thing I know you can sync up
because my phone's synced up to my
laptop
and yeah that's different oh it's
different that's different it is
different because that's that's your
thing yeah same network same um profile
same order and obviously iOS iOS that's
different for the fact that his search
history is connected to hurting yeah
it's a completely different thing well
I'm just saying maybe I don't even say
I'm saying is because maybe the flipping
um the PC at home is his yeah yeah or
something like that maybe so yeah you're
right maybe the PC at her house is his
PC or his Mac or whatever yeah and it's
obviously connected to his I think I
think it does do search history to be
fair because I think if I search
something on my phone yeah if I then
went on Google on my laptop and typed in
like the first three letters that recent
search will pop up yeah so it must be
his device yeah I guess so yeah I guess
so damn yeah man yeah mad like on advice
charge you there's nothing you can do
because at the end of the day he only
he's only livid that he got caught yeah
he's not
out here trying to stop his cravings for
no reason whatsoever yeah he doesn't
want to stop his Cravings he's only
trying to appease you because he got
caught yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah so you
have to charge that even today there's
nothing there's not there's facts bro
he's afraid here's a crave no this is
It's a crave like he's got she has to
charge it and there's there's no other
polite way to say it literally just
charge it and just think is this what
I'm willing to tolerate in my
relationship because now she has to make
the decision yeah there's nothing you
can do anymore because he's got to do
this again next week
so you have to have a charger or cancel
him one of them that's the thing as well
because it's like oh I'm upset because
he's doing this when it's at home and he
could be doing it but he's not he's not
do you think he doesn't know this at
home so just stay vexed charge it or dip
in fact there's no other choice yeah bro
that's mad sorry dude wow okay cool uh
right apparently you've got a question
for the team today I do have a question
for the team I've completely forgot
about that right this is for everyone
yeah
so I saw this on I think someone sent
this to me
um on Instagram it was another I think
it could have been another podcast or
just a random video but would you rather
5 million right now
or one pound per step for the rest of
not for the rest here for a whole year
for 12 months
a million five million right now five
million or one pound per step for 12
months and it goes directly into my
account however you want it bro
step in yeah yeah because it encourages
me to stay healthy and fit
I'm actually getting paid for every
every step every step I take every move
I make yeah yeah
um yeah I'm doing that cool 5ms is Saucy
though yeah five amps right now might be
yeah yeah what's the average like 10 000
steps a day
than an actual average
yeah that's right yeah that's
recommended by a health professional
yeah I don't think that's an average I
don't do 10 000 steps a day yeah I don't
right now if I was making him cake it
says the average is between three
thousand and uh four thousand that's
pathetic okay so let's actually deal
with averages three to four let's say
it's three five right so let's do a day
3500 Times 365. Yes it get close it's
not even close my dude yeah it's not
even close is it even 1.3 1.3 less than
1.3 or you can get five M's right now
all right so what's ten thousand uh
what's ten thousand times three hundred
that's three point six five
000 times 365. so we're still not
getting that now I'll show you the steps
you know yeah if I can do the the 10 the
10 which I can do
10 a day 10 a day I don't think you
could do 10 a day you've got a life
jacket I do have a life but I can just
run and stuff like I can I need three
head I'm unfit bro I need incentive and
this is it how many steps you think I'm
gonna do if you pay me five M's less
than I do now true I'm not doing
anything true true I'm not doing
anything and it's um it's for one year
yeah
it gets even more incentive as well
because I can get five M's right now
yeah or I can dedicate this year to make
sure I can earn more than five amps
good point and at the end of it I'm
gonna look good my knees will be marked
and I'll be knackered but I'll look good
and my pockets will be lined okay
okay REM what are you saying well I'd
want to step it out as well but you're
looking at a calculator
I'm running the mass I'm looking at the
numbers from and to earn the five mil
from steps 13.5 k 13
698 steps per day so lost steps my
um my brother just got um you know
people do stand-up desks yes yes he's
just got one of those treadmills as well
so now he he walks when he's working wow
you might have said a few weeks ago
maybe yeah he got a couple weeks ago um
and he's been doing 13 a day um
yeah he's been walking shredded
not yeah it's gonna be a couple weeks
okay but he has he seen a difference
he's excited okay gang it just reminds
me of the Mr Beast thing because he lost
what he was doing 12 and a half a day I
think for months or so yeah he's lost
weight I might just start walking I
don't know who's gonna pay me a pound I
might just start walking bro
fair fair it helps it does help it helps
it helps but you go to deep would you be
pissed at the end of the year if you
didn't hit your the five mil would you
would you think
well I should have hit the five mil I
should have taken the five mil or
actually I'm short of the five mil but
I'm this much healthier yeah I don't
think I'll be vegetable because if even
if I came out and I made three M's I'll
be I'll be thinking oh damn man but I
know it's my fault yeah yeah yeah yeah
because I'm checking my account every
day I know exactly what's going in there
and I know I'm slacking every day it's
not like it'll be different if I had no
idea how many steps I was taken and at
the end of the year they just paid me
three M's and I was like what the
yeah I've been walking non-stop yeah if
they're paying me every day yeah yeah I
know what I'm doing wrong okay so if I
can't fix that that's my problem bro
okay so you're definitely choosing to
walk in I'm doing steps
it would encourage me to stay fit when
I'm walking yeah Ellis yeah let's go I'm
impatient
straight away that's that young
mentality I love it 22 years straight
away yes yeah gang I love that because
that's the thing you would be
disappointed if you didn't hit that at
the end of the year you just think
what's the point yeah God's sake so yeah
I don't know you know it's 13 bags in
your account every day after two days
you're laughing
yeah yeah yeah
yeah bridge I make 13 bags a day I can
take a day well then again you could
you'd still walk you can walk in and
around the yard yeah you're still going
up and downstairs you're not gonna earn
that much though yeah but yeah you'll
check it Apple watch your thing oh I've
done 300 steps today three bills is that
it three bills yesterday I made 10K I'm
running around yeah yeah don't make me
run rounds bro
I would funny enough I'll pick the same
I would the one pound a day purely
because one health benefits two I think
it would like you said motivate me to
just be out more like just walk
everywhere not drive as much public
transport whatever so yeah definitely
definitely definitely I'd probably walk
yeah man think about the trips to the
corner shop yeah we just jump in your
car yeah and everything's fine what if I
walk I'm gonna make wow I'm gonna make
pee I'm gonna be healthy and it will
probably make me have a better routine
because I'll be now I'll be sleeping
early I'll be waking up early I'll be
drinking loads of water yeah oh I'm
walking I'm walking I think oh bro if I
need to be at the studio by 12 if I get
up tomorrow at seven it means I've got
three hours of walking time before I
have to get in the car and then your
whole life will change the life will
change for a year I'll be in this time
in 2024 I'll be a different person oh
bro you'll be mature sexy and Rich I'll
be a different person and I'll be like
what what's going on and this will just
be rich and fat
Richard fine I have employees
say less but yeah I knew you were going
to choose that one I think it's in
mentally I think it's an age thing
because if you had asked me this
question I'd walk everywhere as it is I
enjoy walking but I I can't be bothered
to
go for that goal of like I need to
I can't be bothered for that goal of I
need to earn more than 5 million if not
I'm disappointed because I'm gonna be so
pissed off if I don't hit that we are
definitely I don't know if you were bro
you'll be a millionaire it doesn't
matter if you've got five four three
years but we definitely fall short of
the five mil though oh 100 I know I know
I would the thing is I know what but I
would it would motivate me two if it's a
month I'm not falling short yeah yeah
it's too long yeah that's a long time
holidays all these Christmas all these
things yeah so sometimes just not
leaving the yard yeah I mean once once
you skip a day one day yeah making that
back up the next day is impossible you
know yeah you're down 13
000 steps that's saying 13 and a half K
steps in one day you're not you're not
getting that back right that's an extra
1.3 if you were to make it up you'd have
to do an extra 1.3
uh 1 300 steps every day for the next 10
days just to get back on track yeah yeah
I'd have to wake up an hour early for
that every single time living my life
like that I'm not living my life
no I'm telling you it's an age thing
yeah you're gonna ask me this five six
seven years ago oh a million I think
three years ago you would have been like
off the ivy hospitality
for what give me the five M's now
because I was doing
mistake yeah you were you were you were
Christmas period yeah nah nah bro at
least you would understand yeah all my
days was I step in I bet you when I was
um I realized that when I was PT in yeah
before I went to work for David Lloyd
when I was ptn I was doing steps I had
no idea I was doing steps yeah until
about today blood and I was sat down
brother again wait I swear I gained
weight that's how you know I was doing
steps because when I obviously literally
just after lockdown my football was
football like my stomach was bubbly
and my chest and shoulders were like
this
I was looking I remember I was standing
in the mirror like this
[Music]
not to me like this and just be like nah
literally on my life I look like them
things from uh Men In Black bro yeah
cockroaches bro that was me
fat stomach and the same size head shape
the cheeks were Rosy I think the first
couple weeks after lockdown if I'm I
slam I was walking yeah bro wow look at
myself like this and say who's
this
bro nobody it's it's actually torn it's
torment looking at yourself naked
as a human being if you just dip
yourself like if you're not really into
Health if you're not really into
anything else come out of like a bad
stint yeah you look at yourself who's
me yeah who's that actually
gonna bang me
people don't actually look at themselves
naked enough no they don't you'll wake
up yeah you you'll wake up you need to
change song yeah yeah because Instagram
can tell you to empower yourself in
whatever they want to say they can say
what they want to say but when you look
yourself in the mirror you know you know
what's wrong
bro Tito can tell me dad bought this and
that bought that but when I look at
myself and the waistband in your boxes
are digging in your skin
and that Muffin Top spilling out
I'll tell you the few parts
the FIFA was different oh you've got the
light in your chest and it's just tease
yeah you're like wrong the nipples
aren't aligning it yeah one nipples down
oh bro
wow I'm walking every day right Ellis
I'm telling you I'm walking every day my
bro
bro I will beg the
wherever the the referee the judicator
the Ombudsman I beg you allows
I beg you allow squats and stuff in the
it's part of the pound let me let me do
this I'm not just walking yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah let me do lunges and stuff so
thin yeah so I want to gain muscle
hell yeah oh yeah that was the
question that's a hilarious question
well played right I've got a very very
quick thread for us to finish on today
so real quick one someone sent this in
to me and said if your ex was on fire
what would you use to put them out okay
I just read the comments bro yeah I've
only got a few all right so someone said
thoughts and prayers oh my thoughts and
prayers oh they really hated them fam
wow thoughts and prayers
and one girl said since he gaslit me so
much I just tell him he's not on fire
I'm currently burning yeah
I can feel it yeah I'm on fire you're
not on fire my God fire it's all in your
head you're like babe I'm gonna
fire what do you mean now you know how
it feels James now you know how it feels
bro I didn't have that I couldn't have
her double down and tell me now you know
how it is
you want to be paid now I will hugger oh
it's the best songs you'll ever receive
this one I put times 100 because I saw a
hundred that just said Gasolina
Gasolina fam no way gasoline Farm just
ignite it
[Music]
in fact Gasolina was one or more fire
was another one no bro it's mine we
don't care about your exes bro one
brother said marshmallows on a stick oh
man's feasting yeah yeah on your ground
oh yeah on your cremation he's eating
off that wow yeah bro people are mad mad
one girl said I'll just throw on another
X
that's probably the best answer yeah
I'll throw one another X next to the
fire a hot can of piss
wow Bros I was waiting for that one I
was waiting for that one as well
the next one brother said I'll put him
out of water what the out of
relationships have you got
you guys said no I'm using War I'm not
making a bird bro last one one chick
said I'd save him go and live your life
all burnt and scarred
wow bro reality would Shake him bro he's
not getting I would run back to my ex
take me please I'm buzzed I've got scars
nobody wants the one that saved me she
has to have me yeah you need to have me
you can't save me and send me off into
the wild no no look at me I'll live in
the forest I would have to live in the
forest because I can't have Society look
at me like this anymore facts bro I'd
move like Tom Cruise and Vanilla Sky
have you seen that I've actually not
seen him in the fam he gets in a car
accident his face is marked
he was a pretty boy and he had Galley
standard that's Thomas yeah yeah
and he was a player standard
and he was banging he was banging
Cameron Diaz Cameron deals tabs I swear
she was banging yeah but she was tired
yeah
so she I think she picked him up
so he I think he clapped her and dashed
her bear in mind I haven't seen this
movie in like 10 plus years so I'm
paraphrasing okay I think he clapped her
dashed her almost like gang gang gang
I'm him
one day he was airing her calls yeah
yeah one day she pulled up and was like
hop in
and he was like no no I'm bless some
blessed and then she must have said just
like a little
um
so weak fan she gave a little got
symbol he hopped in the passenger he
hopped in the passenger and these times
the reason he locked her off is because
he was he started banging Salma Hayek
and he loved her he loves he said the
player days are behind me bro oh my God
this is her yeah summer height was her
bro yeah yeah yeah so he was like gang
gang gang gang gang it was somehow
called Penelope Cruz I can't remember
who the actress was they look very
similar way either way either way um so
but yeah weak-minded Cameron Dia said he
hopped in the whip
and then when I say she sped off she was
doing 95 in in the in the 30s it's a
slowed down nah and she was like I just
understand why you're doing
why like you would do this to me
slow the down we can talk about it
yeah facts and then she's crying just
crying
crash the car I'm pretty sure she died
his face was twist up
Salma Hayek was trying to be on it yeah
but like because she couldn't fam it
he's like wearing a mask stayed in his
yard wearing a mask just going crazy wow
I've actually never seen this good movie
yeah stayed in his yard going crazy
and he was convinced that Salma Hayek
was banging his best friend because they
were they were because they would always
link him together so he would sneak out
and see them out just to see cats oh bro
it's mad
yeah Penelope Cruz Jesus yeah bro she
was a baddie in that movie Jesus 2001
yeah it was a minute ago
um
yeah Penelope Cruz bro Cameron Diaz was
nuts wow but yeah man for this guy good
movie and his new um Mission Impossible
movies coming I've seen a trailer
did he leap off of a tick yeah it looks
hard yeah I saw I saw on Tick Tock they
were doing like behind the scenes and
the trailer he literally did that yeah
yeah it's one thing where he uh a
ranting yeah he loves his stunts he does
he loves he's like 60 bro yeah it's mad
he looks so handsome he's adrenaline is
different let's see it's going to be a
two-part yeah part one yeah it's gonna
be a two-part I have I don't think I've
seen the last two
um I think I have I I'm pretty sure I've
definitely seen the most recent one
because you have seen it you have seen
it because it has um
um Henry cavillin if you remember I
haven't seen it bro I've seen this thing
yeah yeah yeah
this thing I want to see it but I'm not
seeing the film it's it's good it's good
fair play bro yeah all right man gang
fair enough
um but yeah that's the episode guys
right guys thank you very much this has
been a ping episode and um as always
[Music]
foreign